hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 20 of my 1H hour flipping Series
today we are going to be doing fruit
fruit only for 1 hour we're going to be
starting with a much lower cash stack
only about 5
mil um this is something I kind of
wanted to do for a while uh but just
recently decided to actually do it uh
it's me kind low key not a lot of fruit
obviously in the game and even less
they're actually viable uh but I mean
it's supposed to be a challenge so we'll
see how this goes and let's get started
okay guys today we're going to be
starting with only 5 mil again this was
kind of a requested by a couple people
to have a bit of lower level or lower
cash stack
content um so yeah we're going to start
with 5 mil and we'll see how much we can
make from just flipping fruit only all
right let's
go so I had a look at what fruit are
available and the best seems to be
coconut uh followed by like papaya
pineapple and then after that they all
get pretty bad to be honest um so let's
try a coconut to start with it also
happens to be one of the more expensive
items
okay
coconut so we bought for
455 and we sold it for
ah okay let's just leave that for a
second
cuz we have such a low amount of actual
items to do that we have to take
advantage of the couple that might be
okay we bought for 425 and we're selling
it for 408 that is definitely much
better okay uh sorry someand music start
playing 408 and we'll start with the
2K H 4K uh looks like
132,000 every
day
at couple, th000 I
mean it's not impossible it's not going
to be the quickest item ever though now
at least this item is used uh to make
super compost I guess so it might
actually have a a reason to be in
existence pretty decent margin for the
type of item it is so we'll do 5,000
pineapples let's just do 10,000 coconuts
might be our best chance we might want
to start buying them
now again we let's re check the margin
here
455 and okay there we go 10
417 we'll just uh pop that in there
418 and we do
3,000
5K yeah we're going to use most of our
money now on
coconuts and uh
um again let's look up the coconut here
there's a lot more traded actually the
last couple days like 373,000 that is
actually quite a bit um not as much in
the last half an hour but um yeah this
could end up being okay yeah look we
already bought some coconuts okay so
actually these coconuts do seem to be
buying pretty quickly we got 1.8k of
them so
far and we're going to sell them back
for 455 I believe um let's just double
check that
again
yeah 455 not
bad so um on this whole transaction this
might be our winner here because we'll
probably hit the limit on that
eventually uh 455 minus 418 37 if we did
10,000 that would be oh wow three yeah
see just that there is actually not a
bad profit okay so we bought a banana
for
80 um so the the banana seems to have
risen up quite a bit yeah look at that
margin on
bananas all right yeah we'll do
bananas and um
5K I don't know how many yeah 5K seems
probably reasonable I don't think
there's many of these traded every day
bananas don't trade as much as you think
we just we're kind of shooting for
random items here 88 and uh we'll sell
it
[Music]
for 81 yeah sure
whatever
82 and just 5K cooking
apples there even any point of trying to
go for that many all right uh let we get
some papaya fruits to bot uh pineapples
not at all bananas not really at all
coconuts definitely are pretty promising
though okay all our coconuts have
actually sold so that is actually a
decent profit right there uh we sold
them for $450 5 was it
yeah uh 455 -
time uh 1820 is how many we had of them
1820 67k wow well we can't afford that
many yet another 4,000 maybe yeah all
right not bad okay we've sold off all
the Coconuts again for
455 um we haven't bought anymore
unfortunately and uh papayas are slowly
coming through not selling terribly
quickly though and we got some more and
pineapples are surprisingly not buying
at all cooking apples and bananas I'm
not surprised about at all although
you'd think I'd get at least one or two
or something but I just actually got
none okay we've gotten our first uh
bananas
so yeah we're selling those for
80 is ridiculously slow but they have a
pretty big margin on them I mean like 79
minus
58 21 times 112 is a that's 2K profit
right there uh which isn't very good but
I mean if I bought all those it'd be
insane but that's probably not going to
happen our papy fruits are slowly
selling and uh still buying as well
which is kind of nice we found this
weird item called dwell berries now it
definitely does not trade very much
but I have this sneaking suspicion that
it is like a quest item or
something
um no never mind that's not worth doing
okay there we go guys we have
successfully sold 112
bananas um for a 3K profit so there you
go pretty good at return on investment
there um not much else good to be said
about that but uh we have sold off the
papa fruits uh in all seriousness not an
a awful margin there and just say about
to take the coconut out uh we actually
bought a large amount I guess the other
person finally got all those coconut
sold uh so we got 814 we actually put a
new offer in for 2,000 but then a bunch
came through uh which is kind of
exciting actually I think we have more
papaya fruits too and we're selling
those for
424 um we're going to have to kick boot
one of these other offers out here
probably going to the cooking apples
since we have not bought a single one uh
get that o there Coconut's going in
for
455 was
it yeah four
five5 and yeah there we go we got
another 894 coconuts that is awesome and
we still have 30 minutes left to try to
hit this coconut uh limit okay all our
bananas sold luckily someone was baking
some banana bread uh so we got those
sold for 79 um which is not awful that
is like we're getting like 24 or
something GP on that and 632 that's
15K okay uh the papayas have sold uh
almost got Le papayas there so
424 and we bought them for
409 oh [__] we sold all the Coconuts all
at once 453 and we bought them for 418
look at that that is 70k in profit which
is pretty damn good
for sorry coconuts um yeah pretty
impressed there're a lot of people who
need coconuts I don't know why the
bananas have sold as well actually and
um haven't bought any more
though and just do another thousand see
if we can actually flip that in time uh
cuz obviously somebody needed 2,000
coconuts so maybe someone will need
another thousand okay we're down to 12
minutes uh we're going to take out all
our buy offers now now um considering
we'll probably not sell all this anyway
uh coconuts we got the majority actually
of which is kind of exciting okay
whatever we don't have time left to
argue the matter too much oh my God
we've actually sold everything I was not
even pay attention I was just talking
and there we go papayas have all sold
and we have 8 minutes left but I don't
know if this is worth trying to wait it
out I mean to be fair we still have
uh 100 bananas to sell so we'll have to
wait on those oh we got another eight
actually pop those in there for 1K and
hopefully those will sell and yeah we
got eight8 minutes left okay we actually
surprisingly had to reduce our bananas
by about 900 and
uh 1121 GP whatever uh but that being
said everything has
sold and uh because we're in a under 10
mil you'll be able to recognize exactly
how much I made pretty much right away
but we'll hit collect and we'll see uh
so from uh 1 hour of flipping fruits we
have made
263k uh which I would say is not too bad
if you like take into account normally I
start with uh let's say 40 mil or maybe
more like 30 mil and so that is six
times the amount of money that I
normally start with so this isn't really
a fair calculation but if we multiply
that by six that's 1.5 mil not that
there would have been anything else I
could have flipped with more money here
uh but this goes to show that any items
can really be flipped there aren't
really any bad items they're just kind
of bad prices on the
items and yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
if you want to see kind of more laidback
uh relaxed 1our flipping videos of kind
of just random stuff and that was my
original idea just to kind of prove a
point uh but I understand not everyone
wants to see uh [__] coconut flips
the whole time uh but if you did enjoy
don't forget to hit that like button it
let me know if you want to see more like
this and uh hit that subscribe button to
stay subscribed with my more recent
videos all right guys I will see you
guys next
[Music]
time